[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
on behalf of the faculty and staff of
the Yale School of Public Health I
congratulate members of the class of
2023.
we are gathered to celebrate your
achievements and acknowledge this
graduation milestone
my colleagues and I welcome thank and
congratulate all of you who played a
critical role in shaping the aspirations
of all of our graduates of the Yale
School of Public Health
and contributed to your success these
special people extend well beyond Yale
most notably including your parents
Guardians Your Role Models your siblings
your grandparents your extended family
and friends and for some of you your
spouses and partners
we want to think thank all of you who've
made possible the academic and life
journeys of our graduates families and
friends of our graduates donors who've
contributed funds for scholarships and
internships please accept our heartfelt
gratitude as we pause to applaud your
contributions to our ysph graduates
[Applause]
mph graduates you are entering the
public health Workforce at a time of
unprecedented public health challenges
the global poly crisis of climate change
covid-19 racism economic uncertainty
have highlighted the negative
consequences that arise due to
structural inequalities and also the
critical importance of Public Health
some communities have lost faith in
public health professionals and
government officials we are witnessing
the emergence of several new
technologies including artificial
intelligence that have the potential to
disrupt reshape and enhance Public
Health we are evaluating and
reevaluating our relationship with
technology and social media the
challenges that face us as a society are
numerous
numerous challenges however mean
numerous opportunities and there is no
greater time to be in the field of
Public Health
as we know public health is about
preventing disease and promoting the
health and well-being of populations
importantly public health is a science
it's an interdisciplinary lens and it's
an approach to solving problems as you
go out into the world you will have the
opportunity to address long-standing
public health problems and new
challenges as they emerge you are
joining the community of ysph alumni and
as I look out into this Auditorium I am
proud of the work that you have done and
I am very hopeful and I am very
optimistic about our future
you are prepared to tackle the world's
most pressing public health challenges
both the ones that we know about and the
ones that have yet to come
each of you has shown your commitment
and passion for public health
all of you are equipped with a skill set
and interest that the world desperately
needs right now
As you move forward in your careers keep
your minds and hearts open
take risks engage and listen
take care of yourself so that you can
take care of others
work to improve social cohesion and
address loneliness which has become
increasingly prevalent
find joy and look for the positive and
Light which can be found in even the
most underserved communities Advocate
and be activists innovate and affect
change
serving as interim Dean this past year
has been one of the greatest privileges
of my career
I and the rest of the faculty have been
honored to celebrate collaborate teach
learn and practice Public Health with
you you are the president and future of
our field
it now gives me great pleasure to
introduce newshia panapour aslami who
has been chosen by his peers to deliver
this year's student address
prior coming to ysph nusia completed his
undergraduate at the University of
Washington in both chemistry and
biochemistry
while there he worked in Social
determinants of health research at
Harborview Medical Center working
primarily with the homeless population
of Seattle
while at Yale new shiar had been part of
the health Policy Department he worked
with the sorry the Yale New Haven
emergency department as a research
assistant helping to enroll patients
with opioid use disorder in a suboxone
clinical trial
he also
spent time as a TF for Professor Abby
Friedman's microeconomics course and he
was significantly impacted by this
experience
he in turn this last semester through
the health policy practicum in the
Connecticut general assembly with
Senator Saad Anwar working primarily on
Senate Bill 9 aiming to help fight the
opioid epidemic in Connecticut
this August new shower will begin
medical school at Washington State
University's
at Washington State University's Elson s
Floyd College of Medicine it is an honor
and a delight to invite to the podium
our 2023 student speaker nusia panapour
aslami
[Applause]
hey y'all
um
so hello distinguished faculty family
members graduates my parents
as I stand Here among you all I'm
reminded of the main reason that I and
perhaps many of you chose this program
the small class size
that first semester seemed so long ago
when somewhere around 350 of us piled
into the Harkins Auditorium fully
unaware that our biostats professor was
actually a master of the art of doodling
and motivational speaking
we followed that by pretending that
epidemiology wasn't just math for four
months straight
then we spent hours reading and writing
for health policy only to look at our
work and wonder if we use the word
trade-off frequently enough to make
Professor Hockenberry proud
then in social justice we embraced
feeling uncomfortable
some in talking about deeply personal
experiences and others out of an equally
deep fear of being canceled
then we broke apart and all went to our
separate departments
with so many people here I figured I
would say use part of this speech to
explain the various Departments of ysph
to perhaps mitigate some of the
questions you will all get at dinner
after the first semester we all went to
pursue our specific degrees in our own
departments this inevitably resulted in
some personality differences that to a
keen Observer can be used to tell us all
apart
first there are those who continued on
with biostats never to be seen again
if you see a biosats graduate today
please approach them slowly and softly
as this is the first time they've
ventured beyond their computer in two
years
however in reality they Remain the only
ones capable of doing math and will
forever be sought after by the rest of
the school for anything remotely
statistically related
then there are the epidemiologists they
come in two flavors chronic and
microbial
those in EMD spent the last two years
learning a combination of maths
statistics coding and science
and you may be wondering how that
distinguishes them from biostat students
the main distinctions are a white lab
coat a pipette and their need to remind
you daily that covet is still very real
and the new variance genome is
fascinating
CDE folks just want to take away your
soda
they are social when you get to know
them but mostly they are silently
thinking of ways to remove sugar from
your diet
I'm fairly certain if everyone stopped
drinking soda we could probably just
close down the department
next are the environmental health folks
EHS as a department is the prime example
of the bystander effect
all of us know how much worse we make
the planet every day but as long as we
see EHS students we know that we'll be
okay
we look at our planet on fire and then
look at EHS students and say they'll
figure it out
I'll be honest if I see two EHS students
in one day I won't recycle for the rest
of the day
moving on we have the advanced
professional mph program
this is for some Stellar individuals
with Advanced backgrounds most of whom
were able to obtain their mph in a fast
track one-year design and they realized
that there was an opportunity to take on
the same amount of debt as a traditional
mph in half the time
distinct from the advanced professional
program is the executive mph program who
paved the way this year in their
inaugural graduating class
these are brilliant folks who have
already been working or studying in the
field of their interest before they came
to Yale and they came here with a
specific aim in mind for their public
health education
I don't have a joke for them because
these folks will be hiring the rest of
us so we're just honored to have them
here
the SBS department or social and
Behavioral Sciences Department
[Applause]
relax
y'all are just too nice
the SBS students are the ones who always
ask you and how did that make you feel
these are the empaths that set the goals
for an ideal Society of pursuing true
equity for all people they are
counterbalanced with health policy
students who ask the question how
exactly do you want to pay for that
Society
[Applause]
Health policy folks of which I am one
are split fairly evenly down the middle
there are those who focus on true Health
policy and view your state not as a part
of the United States but as a laboratory
to test their radical ideas
then there are those whose degree says
the words Health policy but they refuse
to take any course outside of the School
of Management
these are Healthcare Management students
disguised as policy students
they still understand policy but they'd
much rather create a synergistic
strategy to bring a drug to Market
and finally there's the Healthcare
Management Department
they produce either Hospital
administrators or Consultants with
questionable math skills
the same way some health policy students
have pretended to be management students
the HCM students have been pretending to
be MPA students these last two years
the Healthcare Management track is a
dipped cone it's basically an MBA that's
been dipped into Healthcare
each department has their strengths and
weaknesses their trade-offs if you will
we have many differences but the common
goal remains to tackle the health of the
public from one of these angles
and reflecting on my time here and
thinking of a big takeaway for this
education I keep searching for some
something that would be a solution for
all the division each of us will face in
our futures be it in women's health
global warming vaccines there's always
some level of hesitancy that research
and data simply have not been able to
compete with
it is the topic that comes up in almost
every class and one that I can see
visibly frustrates many of my classmates
after spending our past 2 years studying
in depth are different areas in the
field of Public Health we still are not
believed at times
that feeling leaves you wanting a
solution
luckily I found that solution to be
nothing
one of the most awkward parts of the mph
program at a place like Yale is that you
have an assortment of incredibly bright
and well-intentioned people coming from
all over the world to this one community
in the middle of Connecticut
in doing so our rules become to learn
and ideally practice Public Health in
our new community of New Haven yet we
don't know this community and most of us
will not remain a part of it after today
so how do we talk with people about the
things we learned how do we try and
apply these ideas that we think may
actually have a chance at working
yes you can do advisory groups you can
make sure the community leads the
solutions you can combine quantitative
and qualitative methods but the
fundamental goal is to establish Trust
that trust does not come from any of
those things it comes from the
conversations you have with people that
are truly about nothing
the strongest relationships I've
developed during my time here have been
with strangers in bike shops barber
shops restaurants and other random shop
owners throughout the city and an
assortment of people aged 60 to 75 on
the train
many of these people I don't remember
their names but if we ever see each
other again we will both remember our
conversation to the smallest detail
simply talking to people for the sake of
hearing what they have to say is
severely underrated as a qualitative
research method
getting to know people for who they are
before trying to sell them on the next
big thing in public health is how we
will overcome the many barriers of
misinformation that will be presented to
us moving forward
it's also perhaps the skill we've
practiced most during our time here
we may not have gotten to know every
single classmate but those that we did
have resulted in deeper connections that
will hopefully last beyond New Haven
I hope you all know how much our
interactions with one another will fuel
the work that is to come it's amazing to
think that random conversations had in
the basement of leph or in the study
rooms of 47 College will translate into
new approaches for Hospital
Administration new genomic research a
new vaccine or something that might just
make a community a little bit healthier
or safer
these conversations that began as
nothing will soon translate into solving
real problems
while I may have chosen to come to Yale
for its program flexibility small class
size and yes even the name
the greatest honor has been the
opportunity to get to know you all
thank you for that honor I had a great
time and I hope you will all join me in
continuing to talk about nothing
[Applause]
thank you that was great it's now my
privilege to introduce our distinguished
2023 commencement speaker apoorva
mandevilly Ms mandevilli is a reporter
for the New York Times focusing on
science and Global health
she currently covers the coronavirus
pandemic the monkey pox outbreak
vaccinations the World Health
Organization and the Centers for Disease
Control
she was a part of the team that won the
2021 Pulitzer Prize for public service
for coverage of the pandemic and was
also a member of the team that was a
finalist for the 2021 Pulitzer Prize for
National reporting
she is a 2019 winner of the Victor Cohn
prize for excellence in medical science
reporting and has won numerous other
awards for her writing she is the
founding editor-in-chief of spectrum an
award-winning news site on autism
science
That Grew audit an audience of millions
she has led the team there for 13 years
she joined the New York Times in May
2020 after two years as a regular
contributor her work has been published
in the Atlantic slate the New Yorker
online and the anthology of the best
American Science and nature writing
she co-founded culture disc an
organization dedicated to enhancing
diversity in science journalism and she
was the founding chair of the diversity
committee for the National Association
of science writers
Ms mandevilli has a masters of arts
degree in journalism from New York
University and a master of science
degree in Biochemistry from the
University of Wisconsin-Madison
graduates faculty staff and families it
is my pleasure to introduce aporva
mandaville
thank you
members of The Faculty
distinguished guests family and friends
of the new graduates
and most importantly class of 2023 it is
a huge honor to speak at your
commencement
what bigger vote of confidence could
there be for someone who writes about
public health
it's also my immense pleasure because
you are my people
I spend a lot of time talking to public
health professionals possibly more even
than to my husband and children but
let's not tell them that
you are on the cusp of entry into this
profession at a extraordinary time
in this pandemic in this country in this
world
as I was thinking about what to say to
you all today the thing that occurred to
me over and over again is that public
health and journalism have a lot in
common
we are both committed to Public Service
first and foremost albeit in different
ways
both professions are crucially important
to the functioning of a healthy
democracy
and yet both are underappreciated and
underfunded
for both professions the past three
years have been unimaginably challenging
both have seen serious attrition a
thinning of our numbers just when we
were needed the most
even as we have struggled to do our jobs
the best we can we have come under
attack
as a group and sometimes even
individually
exhausted and dispirited many in both
professions have left or been let go
all of which is to say I feel the same
way looking out at all of you as I do
about talking to journalism students all
that you are choosing this profession
despite these circumstances
and profound gratitude that you're doing
so
I know that you're not choosing to go
into these jobs for the money
and certainly not for fame public health
is only rarely in the spotlight
I've been writing about public health
and infectious diseases for 20 years
which has often meant that very few
people read what I wrote
professionals like you and just a few
others
there have been stories that broke
through the surface of course like the
men who were cured of HIV or about
vaccines for malaria
but by and large people who write about
public health are playing to a select
audience
you know only too well how the Pandemic
upended those trends suddenly people
were interested in the most mundane
aspects of science and medicine suddenly
everyone wanted to know everything about
viruses epidemiology Immunology vaccines
it was surreal to hear terms like are
not and hurt immunity and T cells in
everyday conversations and to be writing
about it for the paper of record
in 2019 nothing would have convinced me
that millions of people would read an
article about the cycle threshold value
of a PCR test
but they did
it was thrilling and terrifying
three years later I'll be honest it's a
relief to be out of the heat to have the
time again to think reflect pay
attention to diseases like TB HIV and
polio which have never gone away
and if anything worsened while we were
preoccupied with the Coronavirus
I bet many public health experts feel
similarly relieved that's the good part
at the same time it's also disappointing
that there seems to be a collective
amnesia for what we as a society have
experienced
it's as if the whole world decided that
the pandemic never really happened
it was a bad dream or it was a grand
conspiracy to control people's lives
here in the United States at least 30
states have moved to limit Public Health
officials Authority
instead of learning from the pandemic it
sometimes feels like we've regressed a
few steps
this exactly a time like this is when it
becomes even more important for both our
communities journalists and public
health professionals to Soldier on and
to assist people despite their
resistance
you have your work cut out for you in a
recent poll 55 of people said they would
trust Public Health institutions to
handle a future pandemic
at least it's more than half it could be
worse
but more than a third said they don't
trust public health professionals
it won't come as a surprise to you but
the numbers are heavily biased by a few
important factors
first they vary by generation
baby boomers are the most trusting of
Public Health while gen xers and
Millennials are about evenly split
between trust and mistrust
the good news is that gen zirs seem to
have no opinion at all
so there's hope to get to them before
they become cynical and mistrustful
the opinions also vary by location
people who live in the suburbs have the
most faith in public health followed by
Urban dwellers
but only about one in five people who
live in rural areas said they believe in
public health
that means those who are in the poorest
parts of the country with the least
access to care are also the least open
to help
the opinions are biased especially by
political affiliation
science has never been free of politics
whether it's policies on HIV Evolution
or stem cell research
party in power has often held deep
influence over science in many ways
and the public too has been divided but
the pandemic undoubtedly deepened that
Rift
more than half of Republicans in that
recent poll said they don't trust Public
Health institutions at all compared with
just 11 percent of Democrats
Public Health coexists with politics but
it should not be political regardless of
what the last three years have shown
some of you will work in red States some
of you in blue States some of you may
work abroad
wherever you end up doing your work you
will have to help all kinds of people
regardless of age race socioeconomic
status or political affiliation
winning back the trust of those who have
become angry and suspicious may be your
biggest challenge
here again there are parallels to
journalism
at the New York Times we pledge to
deliver the news without fear or favor
I would urge you all to do the same
tell the public the truth the whole
truth even if you worry that some of it
will be misused by some people
because if you don't tell the whole
truth
if you leave some things unsaid it
leaves room for others to swoop in and
fill it with misinformation
too often in this pandemic my colleagues
and I have found ourselves uncovering
information that should have been in
front of the public to begin with
I'll give you an example to illustrate
what I'm talking about the covet
vaccines
the vaccines are a miracle of Science
and they've transformed a deadly
pathogen into a mild threat for most
people there's no doubt about that
but all coveted vaccines are not the
same nor are they perfect
like any other vaccine or drug on this
planet they have flaws
they were never all that likely to
prevent all infections
they don't offer lasting protection
especially against infections and
especially in older people
and in some small number of people they
again like any other vaccine or drug
they do cause some side effects
but many public health exports I've
talked to are deeply uncomfortable
having that conversation or shy away
from it altogether
they fear that any discussion about the
weaknesses of vaccines will dissuade
people from getting immunized or that
the information will be misused by
anti-vaxxers a justifiable fear to be
sure
and as a result they've stayed silent
for too long about these flaws
from my vantage point as a journalist
this defensive approach to Public Health
meant that my colleagues and I have had
to hunt for the truth not because it was
being maliciously covered up but because
it was withheld for the Public's own
good
that paternalistic attitude made even
people who generally believe in science
weary and mistrustful
the gaps in data nourished conspiracy
theories they allowed Bad actors to
exploit the seeming inconsistencies to
say see you're being lied to don't
believe them
transparency as scary as it can
sometimes be is the only way to build
trust
I know some of what I've just said seems
Bleak but I also feel hopeful
look at what's happening right here
today with all of you hundreds of
incredibly smart and passionate people
getting ready to go out there and make a
difference
the rest of the world may have forgotten
covet's lessons but you have the
opportunity to help rebuild trust and
prepare us for the future
of course the work ahead of you will not
be easy I've gathered from the hundreds
of experts I've talked to over the years
that it is hard intense and often
thankless
but it's also rewarding and essential
this country and this world need you
your intelligence your compassion and
your dedication to public service
in my experience Public Health people
are among the most driven to help others
and to make the world a better place I
am thrilled to welcome you to their
ranks
thank you again for the great honor of
speaking to you today congratulations to
you to your families and your loved ones
[Applause]
okay we would now like to acknowledge
our student awards for this year's
commencement we ask that all student
award recipients come to Stage to
receive their award when their name is
called
the faculty and I commend all of you for
excellence of your Theses and Capstone
projects it is my great pleasure to
acknowledge the 2023 recipients of the
dean's prize for outstanding mph thesis
The Wilbur G Downs outstanding thesis
prize in international health and the
outstanding mph thesis prize in Health
Equity
the recipients of the dean's prize for
outstanding mph thesis are Emily Alice
Goddard and Caroline Ann Pastrana helson
foreign
the recipient of the Wilbur G Downs
outstanding thesis prize in
international health is Savannah Sammy
sunflower Randy
[Applause]
the recipients of the outstanding mph
thesis prize in Health Equity are Anna
Grace Preston and Sydney husset
Richardson
foreign
the Henry J Chauncey Jr inspiration
award was established in recognition of
Mr Sam Chauncey who developed our
program in Healthcare Management
and fostered its close collaboration
with the Yale School of Management a
former Secretary of the university and
distinguished member of the Yale New
Haven communities Sam has been both an
agent of change
and a dear friend of ysph
this award was initiated by the Health
Management program class of 1999 and is
now sponsored by the school it is given
to the graduating Health Management
student who most exemplifies Innovation
Integrity leadership and community
service
this year's recipient of the Chauncey
award is Jacob Michael Eisner
thank you
[Applause]
the low 11 award for excellence in
global health is awarded to a graduating
student whose work addresses health
promotion and Global health
the recipient is selected based on their
internship experience and overall
academic record as well as their
academic leadership and Community
engagement
Professor Levin was a dear friend to
many a ysph alumnus and the first head
of the ysph international Health
Division I am very pleased to announce
the low 11 award for excellence in
global Health that has been awarded to
Ann Chi ha
thank you
[Applause]
our annual ysph student award for
outstanding contributions to advancing
belong with longwoody sorry
belonging equity and Justice recognizes
one or more graduating mph students who
have demonstrated a significant
contribution towards creating and
fostering a diverse and inclusive
community while at ysph
I am pleased to announce the recipients
of this award are Iman abayazed Abdul
sadig
[Applause]
m
[Music]
Naseem Ashford
thank you
Mommy
and McCune vishwa see desibatla
[Applause]
[Music]
these Awards
these award recipients were recognized
for creating community and implementing
programs to help bring students together
they did significant work in organizing
efforts to increase a sense of inclusion
and belonging for students at ysph
through a range of activities such as
supporting recruitment efforts and
organizing student events
we would now like to acknowledge our
teaching awards for this year's
commencement we ask that all teaching
award recipients come to the stage to
receive their award when their name is
called
the ysph teaching award recognizes a
student who demonstrates outstanding
performance as a teaching fellow
and promise as a future leader the
recipient of the 2023 teaching fellow
award is Sarah Meagle
[Applause]
[Music]
the ysph distinguished student mentoring
award recognizes a faculty member as a
leader in shaping the next generation of
public health professionals and one who
serves as a role model conveys passion
for public health
has clear and high expectations
encourages students to achieve their
full potential is sensitive to student
needs and concerns and makes
extraordinary efforts to help students
candidates for this award are nominating
by graduating students and selected by a
committee of students and faculty this
year the 2023 distinguished student
Mentor award resulted in a tie the
recipients are Sarah Lowe and Josh
Warren
[Applause]
the distinguished teaching award also
called the teacher of the year award is
the school's highest honor to its
faculty bestowed by its graduating
students quality teaching is one of the
most important influences on a student
experience at Yale and this award
recognizes the recipient's leading role
in shaping the next generation of public
health professionals
the 2023 recipient of the distinguished
teaching award is
Chelsea Carter
[Applause]
Sarah Amigo Sarah Lowe Josh Warren and
Chelsea Carter will have their names
inscribed on the awards wall on the
first floor teaching area at 60 College
Street
all right now we will take time to honor
our mph graduates
we ask our graduates to please follow
the direction of staff to proceed to the
stage when your name is called please
cross in front of the podium to receive
your diploma from me a representative of
the Yale School of Public Health Alumni
Association Dr tossos kiriakitis will
also provide you with an alumni pin as
you exit the stage
individual photos will be taken of each
student as they receive their diplomas
these photos and others will be made
available to students and their family
for free later this week along with a
video of the ceremony thus we ask that
guests refrain from taking photos in the
aisles to prevent interference with the
procession thank you for your
consideration
it is now my pleasure to introduce Dr
mayor Desai director of the advanced
professional program
[Music]
who will introduce candidates for the
master public health degree
Mark Evan Abraham
Frank cosiso chukwo amefuna
Kel Kelvin Iram amenyador
[Applause]
Jessica
berenboim
[Applause]
arushi baveja
boyani babishi
[Applause]
Ashok barwani
Ricardo Adolfo Concepcion Gomez
[Applause]
Cassandra Kathleen crifasi
mod a dar
[Applause]
olyn Rita Dumont
takisha Dewan Everett
[Applause]
[Music]
Aaron Gilmer
[Applause]
Mark William josepher
Reza hosseini is not here
Chelsea maduke
[Applause]
hamira McCutchen
Preston Sanders Moore
nirupama natarajan
[Applause]
not here is Cassius iyad oshoa char
anvesh Babu pusala
[Applause]
Constantine Radu
dayung Ryu
[Applause]
Maria sakuro Santos
elephant Allen Jonathan oh
is not here Alan Jonathan Septimus
Jing Ting so
[Applause]
not here is Stuart L Steinman
oh
Allen
[Applause]
Tristan Marvin
oui
[Applause]
Jeffrey Allen Vernon
Jonathan Valentine Wooten
[Applause]
young and baby Haven
foreign
it is now my pleasure to introduce
Professor shuangu ma chair of the
Department of biostatistics who will
introduce candidates for the master of
public health degree in that program
[Applause]
thank you foreign statistics
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
be Italy
evenly
[Applause]
let's eat me here
hello
[Applause]
my YouTube page
you
use your child
[Applause]
[Music]
song
[Applause]
[Music]
mean everyone
[Applause]
not in one
Lou John
[Applause]
ciao
it's now my pleasure to introduce
daughter to the election chair of the
Department of chronic disease
epidemiology who will introduce the
candidates for the master public health
degree in that program
foreign
this is an honor on behalf of our CDE
faculty Yara Abdel Salaam
[Applause]
swirly
yogeshwar Atri
[Applause]
Vanessa Las Mila Blas
Taylor Choi
[Applause]
Ina Cohen
not here but I'll read Marianne rebstock
Cosgrove
Daniel dabila
[Applause]
McCune
Cassie do
Catherine Esther Fuller
[Applause]
and Lyon havlik
Allison Paige Janik
[Applause]
Farah Zhang
soon
[Applause]
namuna
Dana kale
[Applause]
he sung Kim
Matthew Bernard Crick
[Music]
[Applause]
Lauren Ray laudermilk
[Music]
say riyong Lee
Stephanie Lee
[Applause]
[Music]
Iman Lee
[Applause]
when Jin Yang
Hedy Ludwig
[Applause]
ala Mansour
Elizabeth acree McDowell cook
[Applause]
Tamra Dorothy Matha
[Music]
Aryan meet
[Applause]
Madison Jewell Nova cell
Marielle Whitley Quinn
[Applause]
Nikita Reyna
Kimberly Elizabeth Reinhardt
[Applause]
Olivia Marie Rua
Yuan Yee tan
[Applause]
wenya Tien
being new Wang
[Applause]
Maya Marina Wilcox
[Music]
[Applause]
kihan yen
yishai Young
[Applause]
Tony and yep
[Music]
thank you
xinji Zhang
[Applause]
Zhang
[Music]
[Applause]
Eileen Zoo
it is now my pleasure to introduce Dr
vasilis facilio chair of the Department
of Environmental Health Sciences who
will introduce the candidates for the
master of public health degree in that
program
[Applause]
Matthew DeVito
Caroline Elizabeth Erickson
[Applause]
[Music]
clear Latin drishy
[Applause]
zhen Liu
Miran Lopez La Square
[Applause]
Alice Lou
finten Monet
[Applause]
[Music]
Avery naperala
[Applause]
Alexandra
P Richmond
[Applause]
[Music]
Timothy Gary skullerman
[Applause]
[Music]
Julia Freya shredman
no
Zhang Wang
[Applause]
way
she who
[Applause]
Yin
and now it's my pleasure
to call Michael Capello chair of the
Department of Environmental epidemiology
and microbial diseases
who will introduce the candidates for
the master of public health degree in
that program
[Applause]
thank you vasilis and welcome to all of
the graduates
Meredith bagger
[Applause]
Nicole Nicole Marie Bramlett
David kachacy III
[Applause]
[Music]
Nicholas Chen
[Applause]
Wendy Chi
Rachel Elizabeth Davis
[Music]
[Applause]
Ariel kaminer hazy
[Music]
Christina Yuri hijia
[Applause]
Lydia hulkrava
Sarah Christine katsandras
[Applause]
[Music]
Jin Hee Kim
[Applause]
Lily kidfield Vernon
Helena Quan
[Applause]
[Music]
Joseph Gibson jeffrew Lewis
[Applause]
Lin Yang Lee
shrey E Lynn
[Applause]
Hannah leot litwack
[Music]
[Applause]
Angelo Raymond lodato
Fatima maiga
[Applause]
[Music]
Natalie merkabla
[Applause]
Brett martini
[Music]
[Applause]
Molly McLaughlin
Adeline Lee Morris
William Pang
[Applause]
Kian Pham
Abigail Grace Pilcher
[Applause]
on her Pinky
[Music]
Iran chin
Savannah Sammy sunflower Randy
[Applause]
[Music]
Erica Jean rayak
[Applause]
Sakina Erica reams
Edwin Ruiz Fuentes
[Music]
[Applause]
Sydney Steele
Russell Thomas
[Applause]
[Music]
Emily tobig
[Applause]
Kang Tran
foreign
[Music]
it is now my pleasure to introduce Dr
Martin Klein director of the executive
mph program who will introduce the
candidates for the master of public
health degree in that program thank you
[Music]
thank you you are all a witness to
history this is the first graduating
class of the executive mph
Emily Claire baltus
[Applause]
Christian Bibi
Jeffrey beniakar
gourdain bhutani
[Applause]
Stephanie Bittner
we have a two for the price of one
special going on in the executive mph
program
Amy Marie Canfield
Lisa Carter Bawa
[Music]
Samir chandan
[Applause]
Jonathan Ram darianani
Paula demasi sanjuro
[Applause]
James David Diaz
advice
Madeleine Evans Donner
[Applause]
Ari Franco
[Music]
Mary Beth giacoma
[Applause]
sapon goel
Thomas Edward Hayden
[Applause]
Angela Marie leap
James Singh C Lee
Lewis Charles Lynn Jr
[Applause]
David mandelbaum
Matthew McGarrity
[Applause]
challenge
Frank Newland Moore
Owen Moss
[Applause]
Katie Parris
Catherine Rebecca Pearson
[Applause]
Scott Richard Pearson
Natasha delanga Perry
[Applause]
[Music]
bin Tai Fung
Linda Stone
Kylie l tanabi
Martina todoro
Tim Tran
Jeffrey Richard van Lou
Ronaldo guayarama Varian
Chelsea viglas
it is now my pleasure to introduce Dr
Howard Foreman director of the
healthcare
[Applause]
I see as someone who needs no
introduction but I'll continue uh who
will introduce the candidates for the
master of public health degree in that
program
Priyanka Agarwal
[Applause]
munisha Ahmed
Nicholas alafaris
[Applause]
[Music]
Shireen Asif
[Applause]
Mariah Gwendolyn Barnes
[Music]
Jack J barsody
[Applause]
Priyanka Eleanor basak
[Music]
rub breast tesfaye bechele
[Applause]
Judy Chen
[Music]
[Applause]
Deanna chore
[Music]
Jacob Michael Eisner
[Applause]
iridian Yolanda Estrada Ramos
[Music]
[Applause]
smurthy denason
[Music]
[Applause]
GAO
Justin Gower
[Applause]
Arpita goyal
[Music]
[Applause]
Nicholas Hayes
Shruti hole
[Applause]
on her
ingerborg Henrietta Hyde
[Applause]
Alexandra Maria Ivanova
[Music]
Joel jar
Lily Carolyn Johnson
[Applause]
[Music]
hogaband Khalsa
[Applause]
[Music]
Daniel Knupp
[Applause]
[Music]
Les
Bader kreibut
[Applause]
Aishwarya sangam karate
[Music]
[Applause]
Hannah Alexandra labowitz
Michelle tingu Lin
[Applause]
[Music]
Karine ibing Leo
[Applause]
[Music]
Ashley Jan Leo
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel amarachi imbecue
[Applause]
[Music]
MO
[Applause]
Alex Molina
Natalie Norton
[Music]
simulator
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
Rachel pan
bomb Park
[Applause]
akshaya Ragu
[Music]
Ramesh
[Applause]
Leia Saab
Smitha Sabara
[Applause]
Soren jacobal Sagi
[Music]
[Applause]
Hamza Saleh
[Music]
Carla Victoria Sanchez Noya
[Applause]
schwanting tongue
[Music]
who went to
Elizabeth
[Applause]
Claire way
[Music]
Hallie Whitman
[Applause]
Luke Wilder
[Music]
[Applause]
Joya Patricia Young
Jonathan Philip Yee
[Applause]
Andrew Young Zhang
Nathan Zhang
[Applause]
[Music]
Jay Zhang Shri
[Applause]
[Music]
Helen Joel
[Applause]
it is now my great pleasure to introduce
Dr Jason Hockenberry chair of the health
policy program who will introduce the
candidates for the master of public
health degree in that program
[Applause]
Anissa abud
[Music]
[Applause]
zaina Ahmed
olawatufunmi jumi akanumi
[Applause]
Nicole Catherine Anderson
Kimberly Avril tatenda Bako
[Applause]
[Music]
Hannah Pace beef
[Applause]
[Music]
Malia Bernal
[Applause]
Celine Marion bondak
Emily Borland
L Britton
[Applause]
Olivia Kenny
[Music]
Philippa Susan Chadwick
[Applause]
Samantha Dao
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr darmi Desai
[Music]
[Applause]
Patrick disman
Anastasia eberhardt
Sarah Elizabeth Graham
Anna Lynn Hollowell
[Music]
Ethan James Harris
Nicholas hatch
[Applause]
anchi huh
Karina Nicole Hull
[Applause]
[Music]
ibudala
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
azzos
[Applause]
[Music]
Abby kalkai
[Applause]
zainab shemsi Khan
sakshi kushwaha
Alice jiwan quack
[Music]
[Applause]
Liu
[Music]
[Applause]
Megan Lyden
Sarah Meagle
[Music]
[Applause]
sujana nelakanti
[Music]
Nathan vahan Nemeth
[Applause]
Ryan Patrick Orr
[Music]
[Applause]
Jeremy John otridge
[Music]
[Applause]
Sierra otilia kovelman
noosh panapour islami
[Applause]
[Music]
Katarina payone
Neil jayesh Patel
[Applause]
[Music]
Kevin minquoak
nor Rana
[Applause]
Sama rash
[Music]
[Applause]
Jacob Everett Reese
[Music]
[Applause]
Julie Renfro
[Music]
Emma Elizabeth Rutan
[Applause]
[Music]
Arya Singh
Renee Andrea serbu
[Applause]
aneri suthar
[Music]
Steph Highway tan
[Applause]
congratulations
Christina Ling Tong
[Music]
[Applause]
Meredith tullik
jinpeng Wong
Tavi Benjamin wolfwood
[Applause]
[Music]
Joe
it is now my pleasure to call Dr Trace
Kershaw chair of the Department of
Social and Behavioral Sciences who will
introduce the candidates for the mph
degree in that program
all right SBS let's take this home
[Applause]
Abdullah
Catherine Ruth noelani kiala okalahua
akoi
[Applause]
[Music]
Nasim Ashford
[Applause]
[Music]
jasminder Baines
[Applause]
mommy sorry
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Bowen
Davina saxena bakshi
[Applause]
Jordan Kylie Hanson Burton
[Music]
Peyton Ashley cabinets
[Applause]
Alana clay
Kalia Christine Carroll
[Applause]
[Music]
Sydney
check
Monica Jing Chen
[Applause]
[Music]
Ann Chang
Lauren Lehman chin
[Applause]
Denise ciao
Casey McClure Cod
[Applause]
Aaliyah canis D DeJesus
[Music]
Marianne dealing
Alexander Duarte
[Music]
[Applause]
Catherine Dunham
[Music]
[Applause]
Francine airfare
[Music]
Sarah Jane federo
[Applause]
Guadalupe Lupita Galvin tanoco
[Music]
Michael Florian jaresku
Marone Kasai
[Music]
[Applause]
Emily Alice Goddard
Rosa Maria Gonzalez Juarez
[Applause]
[Music]
Olivia Goodwin
[Applause]
[Music]
Divya gumadavelli
[Applause]
foreign
Maggie Blair Hart
[Music]
[Applause]
Caroline and Pastrana pelson
[Music]
[Applause]
Winnie Jade ho
[Music]
Karina Shea
UA Q
Ivan Hurtado
[Music]
Sydney Hassett Richardson
[Applause]
[Music]
Elizabeth
Catherine jadovich
[Music]
Anushka Jane
[Applause]
patil jivalegian
[Music]
Hoon Kong
Isa Khan
[Applause]
Alyssa my son Kim
Shannon Tracy larsuel
Amanda Ann Levy
[Applause]
defna Levine
Anna Lynn Schweitzer
[Applause]
[Music]
Mona McCarey
[Applause]
[Music]
Mitchell Eugene manware
Maritza menchala
[Applause]
[Music]
Helen Wilson Mooney
[Applause]
[Music]
Catherine Moy
[Applause]
[Music]
yashna nainani
essel Nam
Samantha nardella
[Applause]
[Music]
Helen l gov
Benghazi Jessica okoli
[Applause]
[Music]
Gabriella orlea Vargas
David oliveras Gomez
sorry
John Andre Savio Parilla
[Music]
Mary L Pang
[Applause]
[Music]
and Grace Preston
Clara Alexis prisch
[Music]
Jessica oops sorry a little
Jessica Celia Teresa Robles
[Applause]
Brittany Eileen Rodriguez
[Music]
Elizabeth sack
[Applause]
Leah Ann salzano
Jacqueline Sandoval
[Music]
pranav savanier
[Applause]
Noelle cerino
[Music]
Taylor Nicole smithori
Emma Elizabeth Spurlock
Luke thanks
Allison oh sorry
sunny sun
Mira gumati swaminath
[Music]
Claire Lee zappari
Maya Rose to Will
Charles lye Tran Jr
[Music]
Stephanie wall
Victor Wong
[Music]
[Applause]
we're feeling it
Susanna Lee Ward
[Applause]
Anna Terry winick
[Music]
Aya zamores
Yushi John
[Applause]
class of 2023 please stand
congratulations to you all
[Applause]
okay please be seated
I would now like to take a moment to
acknowledge our ysph students who are
receiving their PHD and master of
science degrees from The Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences the 16 doctoral
graduates and 66 Ms graduates are listed
in your program they are recognized more
fully through the graduate schools
commencement ceremony which is where
they are now please join me in
recognizing them with a round of
applause
there
as we approach the end of the ceremony I
address you the ysph class of 2023 the
degrees you have been awarded today are
a testament to your hard work and your
passion for public health we also wish
to thank all the families and friends of
the graduates for joining us in the
celebration all of you in attendance
families faculty staff alike have
encouraged and inspired our students to
succeed in this exciting stage of their
studies
Yale University also wants to
acknowledge that indigenous people
Nations have stewarded through
generations the lands and waterways of
what is now the state of Connecticut
these include Mohegan Massachusetts
Pequot
Eastern Pequot chagatco
Golden Hill pagaset Niantic and the
Quinnipiac and other Algonquin speaking
peoples we honor and respect the
enduring relationship that exists
between these peoples and Nations and
this land
[Applause]
finally thank you most sincerely to our
student affairs team
who's worked so hard to produce this
event thank you Dean Frank Grosso
[Music]
director of student affairs and
registrar Stacy Tuttle
and their entire team alongside my own
colleagues in the office of the dean
they have supported you for the past few
years starting during the application
process and throughout your graduate
experience at Yale please join me in
thanking them for everything they have
done throughout your training at the
Yale School of Public Health
please stay in touch with your teachers
and the AY aph our association for Yale
alumni and Public Health in which you
are now subscribed let us know about the
work you do your successes and your
willingness to advise current students
to receive future summer interns and to
contribute to the annual alumni fund for
scholarships we will always value your
advice and your support and a personal
thank you to students staff and faculty
for their support this concludes our
ysph diploma ceremony
thank you
we ask that the guests remain in their
seats until the representing faculty
members have departed thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign